An aching back, a bad knee, a recurring headache. For many people, this kind of pain is a daily fact of life. More than 20% of U.S. adults suffer from some form of chronic pain, and health economists have estimated that chronic pain costs the U.S. up to $633 billion per year in medical expenses and loss productivity. For many chronic pain sufferers, effective treatment remains elusive, with doctors visits, medications, and even surgeries, giving little in the way of relief. But in recent years, research by psychologists and other scientists has begun to suggest that
背部酸痛、膝盖受伤、偏头痛频发。对许多人来说，这类疼痛是日常生活中的常态。超过20%的美国成年人饱受某种形式的慢性疼痛折磨，卫生经济学家估计，慢性疼痛每年给美国造成的医疗费用和生产力损失高达6330亿美元。对于许多慢性疼痛患者来说，有效的治疗依然难以企及，看医生、吃药甚至手术都很难起到缓解作用。但近年来，心理学家和其他科学家的研究开始表明，
for at least some people, the answer to chronic pain may come not from healing the body, but from treating the mind. What does that mean? How does it work? What's the relationship between our thoughts, feelings, and beliefs about pain and the actual pain that we feel. What does pain look like in the brain? Why do placebo's work? And how can we use what scientists are learning about the brain basis of pain to develop effective new treatments for it? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills.
至少对某些人来说，解决慢性疼痛的答案可能不是治愈身体，而是治疗心灵。这是什么意思？它是如何运作的？我们对疼痛的想法、感受和信念与我们实际感受到的疼痛之间有什么关系？大脑中的疼痛是什么样的？为什么安慰剂会起作用？我们如何利用科学家正在了解的大脑疼痛基础来开发新的有效治疗方法？欢迎收听“心理学对话”（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学协会（American Psychological Association）的旗舰播客，探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。
Our guest today is Dr. Tor Wager, the director of the cognitive cognitive and everyday life. and effective neuroscience laboratory at Dartmouth University. Broadly speaking, Dr. Weager studies how people's thoughts, beliefs, and expectations affect the brain and body. He has a particular interest in the experience of pain. He began his career studying the placebo effect, and today he uses brain imaging techniques to examine what pain looks like in the brain and to try to understand why pain feels the way it feels
我们今天的嘉宾是托尔·韦格尔（Tor Wager）博士，他是达特茅斯大学认知与情感神经科学实验室的主任。总的来说，韦格尔博士研究人们的思想、信念和期望如何影响大脑和身体。他对疼痛体验有着特别的兴趣。他的职业生涯始于对安慰剂效应的研究，如今他利用脑成像技术来检验大脑中的疼痛感，并试图理解为什么疼痛在特定的一组情况下对特定的人会有特定的感觉。
to a particular person in a particular set of circumstances. He's also interested in using his findings to help develop new psychological-based treatments for pain. Thank you for joining us today, Dr. Wager. It's a pleasure to be here, Kim. Let's start with the big question. What is pain? Most lay people think it's a signal that your body sends to your brain to let you know that something is wrong. You get hurt and your body sends up a flare to let you know that something is amiss.
他还对利用自己的研究结果帮助开发基于心理学的新型疼痛疗法感兴趣。感谢您今天加入我们，韦格尔博士。很高兴来到这里，金。让我们从一个宏观问题开始。什么是疼痛？大多数外行人认为，这是身体向大脑发送的信号，让你知道出了问题。你受伤了，你的身体就会发出一个信号，让你知道有些不对劲。
But your research has found that pain is more complicated than that. So what is pain if it's not just a simple signal from our body? to our brain. Pain is an experience that's constructed in the brain. And it depends partly on the signals coming from the body to the brain, but only partly so. It also depends on what your brain knows about the context that surrounding pain. Is it threatening or is it dangerous? What should the brain feel? So essentially, pain as an experience is the result of a decision by the brain that a sensation from the body ought to be treated as threatening and dangerous. So in a paper published in September in the journal JAMA Psychiatry, you and your colleagues
但你的研究发现，疼痛比这更复杂。那么，如果疼痛不仅仅是我们身体向大脑发出的简单信号，它到底是什么？疼痛是大脑构建的一种体验。它部分取决于从身体传到大脑的信号，但也只是部分取决于此。它还取决于你的大脑对疼痛周围环境的了解。它是威胁性的还是危险的？大脑应该有什么感觉？因此，从本质上讲，作为一种体验，疼痛是大脑做出的一种决定，即应该将来自身体的感觉视为具有威胁性和危险性的。因此，在9月份发表在《美国医学会杂志·精神病学》（JAMA Psychiatry）上的一篇论文中，你和你的同事
described a new type of treatment called pain reprocessing therapy. How does this treatment work and how is it related to the definition of pain that you just gave us? Well, Kim, I'd like to start by going back to some of the things that we've learned from neuroscience. There's a wealth of really exciting studies that have been coming out in the neuroscience from animals and from humans over the past years. And what it's taught us is that it's not a one-way street from the body to the brain. That when you have the conception of threat, then signals that are coming from the body to the brain
描述了一种名为“疼痛重塑疗法”（pain reprocessing therapy）的新型疗法。这种疗法是如何运作的？它与你刚才给出的疼痛定义有什么关系？好的，金，我想首先回顾一下我们从神经科学中了解到的一些东西。过去几年里，神经科学界涌现出大量非常激动人心的研究。它教导我们的是，从身体到大脑并不是单向的。当你有了威胁的概念时，从身体传到大脑的信号
that create pain or no susceptive signals become sensitized. So the signals in the spinal cord become sensitized. The signals in the thalamus, which relay signals to the cortex, becomes sensitized. and you get signals in the amygdala and the prefrontal cortex, circuits that are associated with fear, threat, and avoidance. So pain isn't simply processed in one center in the brain. It triggers all of these things. And what triggers these sensitization processes
——即产生疼痛或痛觉感受的信号——就会变得敏感。因此，脊髓中的信号变得敏感。将信号传送到大脑皮层的丘脑中的信号变得敏感。你在杏仁核和前额叶皮层（与恐惧、威胁和回避相关的回路）中获得了信号。因此，疼痛并不只是在大脑的某一个中心进行处理。它会触发所有这些事情。是什么触发了这些敏感化过程，
and what de-escalates them or unwinds them has been a mystery. And that's one of the things that we can understand better by studying treatments like pain reprocessing therapy. So what is pain reprocessing therapy? Well, it's one of a family of psychological and behavioral treatments that are intended to recognize that the brain sensitizes and constructs pain experience in part. It's not all about the body.
又是什么消除了它们或解除了它们，一直是个谜。这就是我们通过研究像疼痛重塑疗法这样的疗法可以更好地理解的事情之一。那么，什么是疼痛重塑疗法呢？它是众多心理和行为疗法中的一种，旨在认识到大脑在一定程度上会使疼痛体验敏感化并构建疼痛体验。这并不完全与身体有关。
And then attempts to unwind a cycle of fear and avoidance and increased pain. And this happens in two ways. The first part is, conceptual. It's natural to think of, let's say you injure your back. That's a frightening experience. And you don't know what it means for your future. Is it mean that you're going to be in pain for a long time? Is it a sign of damage? It's natural to think that it is. But when that happens, then that pain becomes threatening. And when pain is threatening, it becomes attended. And when it's attended, it becomes amplified. And over time, then, pain gives rise to
然后试图解除恐惧、回避和疼痛加剧的循环。这通过两种方式发生。第一部分是概念上的。很自然地会去想，假设你伤了背部。那是一种可怕的经历。你不知道这对你的未来意味着什么。这是否意味着你将长期处于疼痛之中？这是损伤的迹象吗？人们自然会这么认为。但当这种情况发生时，疼痛就变成了威胁。而当疼痛具有威胁性时，它就会受到关注。当它受到关注时，它就会被放大。随着时间的推移，疼痛就会在大脑中引发
threat signals in the brain, which give rise to more pain. And over time, your brain is learning that this is the most important thing that's happening and the thing that you should be amplifying and attending to. So there's a feedback cycle where pain is ramped up over time. And that's what we think underlies this sensitization process. So part of the antidote to that is simply realizing that pain is not a sign of damage. Now, this is tricky. because acute pain often is. So you should bring your ankle, which I did a few weeks ago. And, you know, yes, it's a sign of tissue damage.
威胁信号，从而引发更多的疼痛。随着时间的推移，你的大脑正在学习，这是正在发生的最重要的事情，也是你应该放大和关注的事情。因此，这是一个反馈循环，疼痛随时间不断加剧。我们认为，这就是这种敏感化过程的基础。因此，解决这个问题的部分对策，仅仅是意识到疼痛并不是损伤的迹象。现在，这很棘手，因为急性疼痛往往是这样的。所以你扭伤了脚踝，我几周前就扭伤了。而且，你知道，是的，这是组织损伤的迹象，
It's a dangerous signal that says stay off of that ankle. But for many people, once pain becomes chronic, there's been this transition process where the body has healed and what's driving the pain and what's causing it is, in fact, this sensitization in neural circuits. And so in that case, realizing that it's just pain, it doesn't signal injury is the first step to unwinding that process and reducing the fear and threat and then reducing the pain.
这是一个危险信号，告诉你不要踩那个脚踝。但对许多人来说，一旦疼痛变成慢性的，就会有一个转变过程，即身体已经痊愈，而驱动疼痛和导致疼痛的原因实际上是神经回路中的这种敏感化。所以在这种情况下，意识到这只是疼痛，它不预示着受伤，是解开这个过程、减少恐惧和威胁、进而减轻疼痛的第一步。
So in a sense, the anticipation of future pain kind of, it's like an endless feedback loop. Is that what you're saying? It's a feedback loop. That's right. And I think that the feedback loop is grounded in what you believe pain means. What is the signal value of pain? So if pain, for example, you injure your back and every time, time you get a twinge in your back, you believe that's injuring your tissue. That's causing further
所以从某种意义上说，对未来疼痛的预期有点像一个无休止的反馈循环。这就是你想说的吗？这是一个反馈循环。没错。我认为，反馈循环的基础在于你对疼痛含义的信念。疼痛的信号价值是什么？所以，如果疼痛，比如你伤了背部，每一次你的背部出现一阵刺痛，你都认为那是在伤害你的组织。那会造成进一步的
damage. Then pain is scary, and it makes sense to amplify it. But if that pain is a residual, one of my colleagues, Bonnie Epcarian, calls it a memory of pain. You know, it's embedded in your brain circuits and your back is actually okay. And your brain circuits are going haywire and firing like crazy and that's a memory. And so you say, hey, that's not, that's not damaged. That means that's just pain. It's safe. And so what PRT does, really first and foremost, is help people to realize that the pain is actually safe. It's not a danger signal. It's a false alarm. And that sets the stage for other processes that can help unwind the cycle of fear and avoidance and pain. A second principle is if the pain is, in fact, just pain and it's not dangerous, then it's okay to experience
损害。那么疼痛就很吓人，放大它是有道理的。但如果这种疼痛是残留的——我的同事邦尼·埃普卡里安（Bonnie Ekperian）称之为“疼痛的记忆”。你知道，它嵌入在你的大脑回路中，而你的背其实没事。你的大脑回路正在发疯似地放电，那只是一种记忆。所以你会说，嘿，那不是，那不是损伤。那意味着那只是疼痛。它是安全的。因此，PRT（疼痛重塑疗法）首要且最重要的作用，就是帮助人们意识到疼痛其实是安全的。它不是危险信号。这是一个虚假的警报。这就为其他有助于解除恐惧、回避和疼痛循环的过程奠定了基础。第二个原则是，如果疼痛实际上只是疼痛，而且并不危险，那么体验
pain. It's okay to move in ways that are painful. So instead of avoiding bending or twisting or lifting, it's okay. It's just pain. And so you can actually engage in those feared movements and even painful movements in a safe setting, right, with support and the realization that that it's actually safe. And for me, what I think of, you know, what this treatment is doing, it's this one-two punch where first there's the support for understanding that it's not a sign of tissue damage, it's just pain, and then putting that into practice and engaging in painful and feared movements, which then normalizes the pain over time and helps you realize in an embodied way that this is really true for you.
疼痛是没问题的。以会引起疼痛的方式活动是没问题的。因此，不要去避免弯腰、扭转或提重物，这没关系。这只是疼痛。所以你实际上可以在安全的环境中，在支持下并认识到它其实是安全的条件下，进行那些令人害怕的动作甚至是会引起疼痛的动作。对我来说，我认为这种疗法正在做的是一种“组合拳”：首先是支持人们理解这不是组织损伤的迹象，这只是疼痛；然后是将其实际应用，进行引起疼痛和令人害怕的动作，这会随着时间推移使疼痛正常化，并帮助你以一种切身体会的方式意识到这对你来说确实是真的。
Some of our listeners may have heard of other psychological treatments for pain like cognitive behavioral therapy that is pretty widely in use. But how does pain reprocessing therapy compare with CBT? What's different about it? PRT shares a lot of principles with CBT and with ACT, acceptance and commitment therapy and other techniques, pain education, pain neuroscience education. and principles that many gifted pain specialists have discovered and rediscovered. So a common theme is this realization that pain is just pain.
我们的一些听众可能听说过其他针对疼痛的心理疗法，比如在临床上相当广泛应用的认知行为疗法（CBT）。但是，疼痛重塑疗法与CBT相比如何？它有什么不同？PRT与CBT、ACT（接纳承诺疗法）以及其他技术、疼痛教育、疼痛神经科学教育有很多共同的原则。
It's not damage. And different types of therapies start to diverge in where they go from there. So the standard line in CBT and act is often to say, well, we don't know what's actually causing the pain. And we don't know if you'll ever get better. Your neurosurgeon said you're always going to be in pain? Well, we don't know. Maybe you will.
许多才华横溢的疼痛专家都发现并重新发现了这些原则。因此，一个共同的主题是认识到疼痛只是疼痛。它不是损伤。而不同类型的疗法在从那以后走向何方开始出现分歧。因此，CBT和ACT的标准做法通常是说：“嗯，我们不知道究竟是什么引起了疼痛。我们不知道你是否会好起来。你的神经外科医生说你永远都会疼痛？好吧，我们不知道。也许你会。”
And so don't do anything that hurts. We're going to help you learn to manage it, cope with it, live with it. PRT takes a much more definitive position. What it says is, you know, after having been examined and, you know, your spinal images looked at, available evidence to rule out a physical or structural cause of ongoing pain, it says, we are pretty sure that this pain is caused by central sensitization in your brain circuits. And therefore, it is okay to move with pain. And furthermore, you don't have to live with pain the rest of your life.
所以“不要做任何会痛的事。我们要帮你学会管理它、应对它、与它共存。”PRT采取了更加明确的立场。它说的是：“在经过检查，看过你的脊椎影像，并利用现有证据排除持续疼痛的物理或结构性原因之后，我们相当确信这种疼痛是由你大脑回路中的中枢敏感化引起的。”因此，带痛活动是没问题的。此外，你不需要在余生中都忍受疼痛。
There's actually a cure. You can get better. So that's pretty different than what standard CBT does. Now, there are CBT practitioners out there who will do exactly what I'm telling you now. So CBT is different in different people's hands, right? It's practiced differently. But this idea that you're providing really a definitive positive explanation for what's causing the pain.
实际上是有治愈方法的。你会好起来的。所以这与标准的CBT有很大不同。现在，也有一些CBT从业者会做我刚才对你说的完全相同的事情。所以CBT在不同人手里的做法是不同的，它的实践方式各不相同。但是这种为你正在经历的疼痛提供明确的积极解释的想法，
And I think for most people in chronic back pain, for example, it's the right explanation. That can really make a big difference. A second difference is in the exposure part. So one of the oldest principles in psychology is that if you're exoner, you're exonerative. exposed to something that's feared in a safe context, that's one of the best ways to unlearn or extinguish that fear. So, for example, if you're getting treatment for a spider phobia, the exact thing you want to do is be exposed to spiders. You know, and you start by just maybe imagining spiders, and then there's maybe one in the room with you, and it gets a little
我认为对于大多数患有慢性背痛的人来说，例如，这是正确的解释。这真的能产生巨大的影响。第二个不同之处在于暴露部分。因此，心理学中最古老的原则之一是，如果你在安全的环境中暴露于某种可怕的事物，这是消除或熄灭这种恐惧的最好方法之一。例如，如果你正在接受蜘蛛恐惧症的治疗，你最想做的事情就是接触蜘蛛。你知道，你从想象蜘蛛开始，然后房间里可能有一只蜘蛛和你在一起，它变得越来越
closer and closer. And you gradually desensitize or extinguish that threat response. Well, in the course of these studies we've been doing, I started thinking about chronic pain, much like a fear disorder. So you actually have to expose yourself in order to realize and teach your brain essentially that those sensations are normal. They are actually okay and they're safe. And you have to unwind that over time. Now, that's something that's practiced fairly widely in Europe.
近。你逐渐使这种威胁反应脱敏或熄灭。好吧，在我们一直在做的这些研究过程中，我开始把慢性疼痛看作类似于一种恐惧症。所以你实际上必须让自己暴露出来，以便认识到并本质上教导你的大脑，这些感觉是正常的。它们实际上没问题，而且是安全的。你必须随着时间的推移解开这个结。现在，这在欧洲是相当广泛实践的做法。
So pain exposure therapy is a big deal. It's practiced in various pockets throughout the United States as well, but it's much less prevalent. And so I think that this realization that that exposure piece is really important is part of the package of what makes PRT work. So it's kind of embrace the pain, don't fear it. And so particularly if you have something like chronic back pain, which I've had, and I know a lot of people have had, that the more you fear it, it's a self-fulfill. prophecy, then you will always have the pain unless you work through it. Is that what you're saying? That's right, Kim, but there's some subtlety here as well. So I think one of the places that people start from that doesn't work is this idea that you can just push through it. You know, you just
因此，疼痛暴露疗法（pain exposure therapy）是一件大事。它在美国的各个角落也有所实践，但没有那么普遍。所以我认为，认识到暴露这一部分非常重要，是使PRT发挥作用的整套方法的一部分。所以这有点像拥抱疼痛，不要害怕。因此，特别是如果你有什么东西比如慢性背痛——我曾经有过，我也知道很多人有过——你越害怕它，这就是一个自我实现的预言，那么除非你克服它，否则你将永远感到疼痛。这就是你想说的吗？正是如此，金，但这里也有一些微妙之处。所以我认为人们开始时行不通的方法之一是这种你可以硬挺过去的想法。你知道，你只是
say, I'm a tough person. I'm not going to let this bother me. And it's funny that that actually often isn't very effective. And what might be happening is that you, you're essentially trying to ignore the pain, but without the scaffolding or structure for what actually is going on. And so underneath that toughness and that push through it and superperson mentality is this idea that, hey, this is really unusual and it actually really hurts. And it's scary. And so maybe not having the narrative for what's happening to you and trying to override that and pursue it often isn't that helpful. So I think changing how we conceptualize pain in the first place is a key part of this. Much of your work in recent years has focused on finding brain
说：“我是一个坚强的人。我不会让这困扰我。”有趣的是，这通常往往不是很有效。可能发生的情况是，你本质上是在试图忽视疼痛，但却没有关于到底发生了什么事的理论基础或结构。所以在那种坚强、硬挺和超人心态的背后，是这样一种想法：“嘿，这真的很不寻常，而且真的非常痛。这很可怕。”因此，如果没有发生在你身上的叙述，并试图强行压制和追求它，通常并没有那么大帮助。所以我认为首先改变我们如何概念化疼痛是其中的一个关键部分。你近年来的大多数工作都集中在寻找疼痛的
biomarkers for pain, looking for ways to actually identify pain in the brain. Are you able to do that now? In other words, can you look at a functional MRI image of a person's brain and tell whether they're experiencing pain? Yes and no. So we start. doing this work on brain biomarkers because not to recapitulate pain reports. Never because we don't believe people in pain. We do. If you say you're in pain, I believe you. It's pain.
大脑生物标志物，寻找在大脑中实际识别疼痛的方法。你现在能做到这一点吗？换句话说，你能看一个人的大脑功能性磁共振成像（fMRI）图像并判断他们是否正在经历疼痛吗？可以，也不可以。所以我们开始
But the real question is, what exactly is causing that in your brain? And are the factors in your brain that are giving rise to your pain the same as my pain? Is it the same if you hit your thumb with a hammer, versus experience chronic ongoing neck pain. Those are the things that we don't know much about. So what are the processes that give rise to it? What are the mechanisms? And therefore, how do we intervene?
做这项关于大脑生物标志物的工作，不是为了重复疼痛报告。绝不是因为我们不相信处于疼痛中的人。我们相信。如果你说你在痛，我相信你。这就是疼痛。但真正的问题是，究竟是什么在你的大脑中引起了这种疼痛？你大脑中产生疼痛的因素是否与我的疼痛相同？当你用锤子砸到大拇指时，与经历长期的持续性颈部疼痛相比，这是否相同？这些都是我们不太了解的事情。那么，是什么过程导致了它？机制是什么？因此，我们又该如何干预？
So that's why we started looking for brain biomarkers of pain. And what we've been able to find over the last, about a decade of work, is that if we're measuring an immediate evoked pain sensation, we can do a pretty good job at predicting from your brain how painful that's going to be for you. So that means that people look pretty similar when they're experiencing immediate ongoing pain. So I can take a bunch of people's brains and figure out what is it, you know, what combination of things that we can measure in a functional MRI scan that predict that.
这就是为什么我们开始寻找疼痛的大脑生物标志物。在过去大约十年的工作中，我们能够发现的是，如果我们测量即时的诱发疼痛感觉，我们就能做得很好，根据你的大脑预测这对你来说会有多痛苦。这意味着人们在经历即时持续疼痛时，大脑看起来非常相似。所以我可以观察一群人的大脑，弄清楚它是什么，你知道，我们可以在功能磁共振扫描中测量哪些事物的组合来预测这一点。
And then I can do a pretty good job at applying that model to your brain and predicting when you're going to feel. more pain versus last pain. We've tested that across probably about 50 different published cohorts of people from across the world with a wonderful group of collaborators. So we have people from Europe, Asia, North America, South America, and it works well. And we've also found that it works well across different types of evoked pain. So if it's heat or pressure or a laser or an electrical shock or even a visceral stimulus, which is actually a rectal balloon that's inflated, that some of my collaborators are doing this kind of work in gastroenterology, that there's a common core set of brain features that are shared across all of these types
然后我可以把这个模型应用到你的大脑上，并很好地预测你什么时候会感到更多的疼痛，什么时候会感到较少的疼痛。我们与一个优秀的合作者团队一起，在来自世界各地的约50个不同已发表的人群队列中对此进行了测试。所以我们有来自欧洲、亚洲、北美洲、南美洲的人，它运行良好。我们还发现它在不同类型的诱发疼痛中也很有效。因此，无论是热、压力、激光、电击，甚至是内脏刺激（实际上是一个膨胀的直肠球囊——我的一些合作者正在胃肠病学领域做这种工作），在所有这些类型的疼痛中都有一套共同的核心大脑特征。
of pains. Now, what we don't know is when it comes to chronic pain, the picture is a lot more complicated because now we're not studying an immediate experience only that we can track over time. Certainly that's a huge part of it. We're also studying the characteristics of the people who have pain. And it looks like there is an element, of course, of this somatosensory no-susceptive pain circuit that may be preserved in chronic pain. And it's important in some aspects. But it looks like the quote unquote chronic pain brain is much more. And what comes out that's special to chronic pain seems to be the involvement of systems for threat, avoidance, and fear.
现在，我们不知道的是，当谈到慢性疼痛时，情况要复杂得多，因为现在我们研究的不只是我们可以随着时间追踪的即时体验。当然，这其中很大一部分是。我们还在研究有疼痛的人的特征。看起来当然有一个躯体感觉-痛觉感受疼痛回路的元素，它可能在慢性疼痛中得以保留。它在某些方面很重要。但看起来所谓的“慢性疼痛大脑”要复杂得多。而对慢性疼痛来说很特别的东西，似乎是威胁、回避和恐惧系统的介入。
So if you think about it, these are systems in the brain that they're not registering the immediate sensation necessarily. They're taking that sensation and making a decision. Do I avoid this? or do I, you know, do I pursue it again? You know, I went on a roller coaster. I felt, you know, disoriented. I'm moving around.
所以如果你想想看，这些是大脑中的系统，它们不一定只是记录即时的感觉。它们是在获取这种感觉并做出决定：“我是要回避这个，还是……”你知道，或者“我要再次追求它吗？我去坐了过山车。我感到，你知道，迷失方向。我四处移动。”
I said all these sensations. Well, is that good thing or bad thing, right? Some people say, I'm never going to do a roller coaster again. So that's the avoidance circuit. And that's the circuit that seems to be quite important for, you know, for chronic pain patients. So these kinds of brain signatures you're talking about, will this help with the problem of quantifying pain. Like, I know most doctors will use a numerical pain scale or, you know, smiley, frowny
我说所有这些感觉。好吧，这是好事还是坏事？有些人说：“我再也不去坐过山车了。”这就是回避回路。对于慢性疼痛患者来说，这个回路似乎相当重要。你所说的这种大脑特征，会有助于量化疼痛的问题吗？就像，我知道大多数医生在要求患者描述他们的疼痛时，会使用数字疼痛量表，或者，你知道，笑脸、哭脸
faces when they ask patients to describe their pain. But it's hard, if not impossible, to know if my five on a pain scale of 1 to 10, is the same as your 5. Could there be a more standard or reliable way to quantify pain? A lot of people hope so. And when you think about a pain biomarker, that's maybe one of the first thing. you think of. You know, is it pain or not and how strong is it? And that's certainly what we're targeting when we look at these brain measures. But I don't envision a world where patients
图标。但是，要弄清楚我在1到10的疼痛量表上的5是否与你的5相同，即使不是不可能，也很困难。有没有一种更标准或更可靠的方法来量化疼痛？很多人都这么希望。当你想到疼痛生物标志物时，这可能是你首先想到的事情之一。你知道，它是疼痛与否？有多剧烈？当我们查看这些大脑测量指标时，这当然是我们所针对的目标。但我并不设想这样一个世界：患者
get scanned to find out how much pain you're really in. You know, I don't think that's the right, that's the right way to think about it. I think about these brain measures being used in a different way. I think about them being used to say, okay, you're in pain. I just am going to ask you, if you say it's a level seven, it's a level seven. If you say it's an 11 out of 10, that's okay too. I don't need to know if, you know, I mean, I shouldn't be giving you a procedure or not based on whether you say 11 or 7 or 4. But what I should be doing is saying, okay, you're in a lot of pain. Where is that pain coming from? And you can think about two different cases, right? Let's say I have pain in my lower back. Now, that might be because there's a, there truly is a pinched nerve in my back, and I'm getting constant no-susceptive input so that the right thing to do is to feel pain, because I'm just getting that signal all the time. The other possibility, or another possibility, is that the signals coming up from my back
接受扫描以查明你到底有多痛。你知道，我认为这不是正确的思考方式。我认为这些大脑测量指标正被用于不同的方式。我认为它们被用来表达：“好吧，你很痛。我只是要问你，如果你说这是7级，那就是7级。如果你说这是10分里的11分，那也没关系。我不需要知道，我的意思是，我不应该根据你说是11、7还是4来决定是否给你做一个手术。”但我应该做的是说：“好吧，你很痛。这种痛是从哪里来的？”你可以考虑两种不同的情况，对吧？假设我下背部有疼痛。现在，这可能是因为，我的背部确实有一个压迫的神经，我一直在接受持续的痛觉感受输入，所以正确的事情就是感到疼痛，因为我一直在接收那个信号。另一种可能性，或者另一种可能性是，从我背部传上来的信号
are actually normal, and my amygdala, let's say, is, you know, hyper-reactive to that sensation. Now, the first person, you should explore more. Maybe you do an invasive diagnostic test. Maybe you do surgery, right? But the second person, the surgery is never going to work for them. It can only make them worse because the problem isn't in their local tissue in their back. The problem is their amygdala, so to speak. So what a biomarker can do is help us determine what's the locus of that pain, what's really driving it,
实际上是正常的，比如说，我的杏仁核对那种感觉过度反应了。现在，对于第一种人，你应该做进一步的探索。也许你要做一个侵入性诊断测试。也许你要做手术，对吧？但对于第二种人，手术对他们永远不会起作用。它只会让他们更糟糕，因为问题不在于他们背部的局部组织。可以说，问题在于他们的杏仁核。因此，生物标志物可以做的是帮助我们确定疼痛的中心在哪里，是什么真正在驱动它，
And how consistent is that with what's coming up from the body versus something that's constructed in the brain itself, where we need different kinds of treatments. And let me add to that that the stakes are really high here. This is important because thousands of people get surgery in the United States each day, and a substantial fraction of those surgeries are not necessary. And not only is that expensive and costs in recovery time and costs in long-term cognitive impairment, after people, you know, come out of surgery. But many of those people end up worse than before. You know, so like, you know, think of back surgery, right? You're taking, and some back surgeries are wonderful.
这与身体传上来的东西相比，有多大的一致性？与在大脑本身中构建的东西相比又如何？我们需要不同类型的治疗。让我补充一点，这里的利害攸关。这很重要，因为在美国，每天都有成千上万的人接受手术，其中相当一部分手术是不必要的。这不仅昂贵，而且消耗恢复时间，并导致人们做完手术醒来后出现长期认知障碍的成本。但其中许多人的情况最终比以前更糟。你知道，所以就像，想想背部手术，对吧？你在进行，有些背部手术棒极了。
I have friends who have benefited from multiple back surgeries. My dad had multiple back surgeries. My mom's had back surgeries, right? You know, I might one day, too. But if you think about the spinal cord is this amazingly intricate, complex, a bit of neural machinery. It can learn to walk on its own. It can avoid obstacles and dangers on its own, right? So it's part of our brain. And if you open up the back and you start doing stuff there that affects the nervous system and affects the inflammatory milieu around that,
我有朋友从多次背部手术中受益。我爸爸做过多次背部手术。我妈妈做过背部手术，对吧？你知道，我有一天可能也会。但如果你认为脊椎是一个极其错综复杂、极其复杂的神经机械组织。它可以自己学会走路。它可以自己避开障碍物和危险，对吧？所以它是我们大脑的一部分。如果你打开背部，开始在那里做一些会影响神经系统并影响周围炎症环境的事情，
you're rolling the dice, you know, and some surgeries are pretty highly effective and pretty safe and others are really not. And so, you know, many, many surgeries are done that are not safe and, in fact, failed back surgery syndrome is estimated at between 20 and 40 percent of back surgery patients in some studies. So that's a lot of people, if you didn't need that and that ends up ruining your life, you know, that's a lot of people who are being affected. Well, that brings to mind the concept of placebo and the effects that placebos can have. And I know you began your career studying the placebo effect. So what? we know about how and why it works, and are there times in situations when it works better
你就是在碰运气，你知道的，有些手术非常高效且相当安全，而另一些则真的不是。所以，你知道，许多许多不安全的手术都被做了，事实上，在某些研究中，失败背部手术综合征（failed back surgery syndrome）估计占背部手术患者的20%到40%。所以那是很多人，如果你并不需要它，而那最终毁了你的生活，你知道，有很多人受到了影响。好吧，这让我想到了安慰剂的概念以及安慰剂可以产生的影响。我知道你的职业生涯始于研究安慰剂效应。那么我们
than other times in situations? Yeah, the reason that we started developing pain biomarkers in the first place was really so that we could study the placebo effect. So there have been many decades of research showing that if you change the psychological context surrounding pain, and also surrounding people's experiences of emotional rejection, romantic rejection and things that create depression and other experiences as well, that there really are large effects on how people report feeling. And the big question, one of the big questions has been, well, is this just people fooling
对它是如何以及为什么起作用的了解有多少？有没有一些时间和情况，它比其他时间和情况起作用得更好？是的，我们首先开始开发疼痛生物标志物的原因，其实就是为了能够研究安慰剂效应。因此，几十年的研究表明，如果你改变疼痛周围的心理环境，以及人们对情感拒绝、浪漫拒绝以及产生抑郁和其他体验的情绪体验的周围环境，它确实会对人们报告的感受产生巨大影响。最大的问题，也是重大问题之一，就是：“这只是人们在自欺欺人吗？这是他们决策过程中的一种偏见，他们以为自己感觉好些了，但实际上并没有？还是正在发生真正的改变？”因此，我们对疼痛中的安慰剂效应做了一些最早的脑成像研究。当我们在这些最初的研究中给人们假治疗时，它是一种皮肤上的乳膏，我们告诉人们这是一种有效的镇痛药。这真的很棒。
themselves? Is it a bias in their decision making that they think they're feeling better, but they're actually not? Or is there a real change that's happening? And so we did some of the first brain imaging studies of placebo effects in pain. And when we give people a sham treatment in these first studies, it was a cream on the skin that we told people was an effective analgesic. It was really great.
它会减轻你的疼痛。我们正在研究这在你的大脑中是如何起作用的。然后他们接受了一个热探针。这有点像拿着一杯你想放下但又暂时放不下的热咖啡。所以我们提供这种诱发的疼痛，当人们使用安慰剂乳膏时，他们的疼痛大大减轻了。随之而来的是，大脑发生了变化。
It's going to relieve your pain. We're studying how this works in your brain. And then they get a hot probe. It's kind of like holding a hot cup of coffee that you want to put down, but you can't put down just yet. So we deliver this evoked pain. and when people get the placebo cream, their pain is reduced fairly substantially. And along the way, then, there are changes in the brain.
因此，你激活了前额叶皮层，并去活化了大脑中一些对产生疼痛体验以及围绕疼痛的恐惧和痛苦很重要的中心。我们发现的另一件事是，当你接受这种假治疗时，你会在大脑中释放内源性阿片类物质，这是大脑天然的止痛剂。因此，大脑中正在发生一个积极的过程。顺便说一句，吗啡和其他阿片类药物之所以能在一定程度上阻断疼痛，是因为你的大脑拥有天然的受体，你知道，以及它产生的与这些受体结合的天然化学物质。
So you activate the prefrontal cortex and you deactivate some of the centers in the brain that seem important for creating the experience of pain and the fear and suffering around the pain as well. Another thing that we found is when you get that sham treatment, you, release endogenous opioids in the brain, which are the brain's natural pain killers. So there's an active, you know, process that's happening in the brain. And by the way, the reason that morphine and other opioids work to block pain to the extent that they do is because your brain has natural receptors, you know, and natural chemicals that it produces that bind to those receptors.
所以，你知道，这就是阿片类系统存在的部分原因。因此，当你认为自己得到了真正能帮到你的东西时，人脑中确实会产生这种内源性反应来缓解疼痛。安慰剂效应是普遍存在的吗？我的意思是，我们所有人都能被安慰剂诱骗而感觉好些吗？还是更像是催眠，比方说，有些人比其他人更容易受影响？安慰剂效应存在着大量的变异性，包括产生它的因素是什么以及谁更容易受影响？因此，在这一点上，凭借几十年来精彩的研究，我们知道这取决于很多事情。没有单一的安慰剂效应，而是有许多安慰剂效应。
So, you know, that's the reason for being of the opioid system in part. So there really is this endogenous response in a person's brain that can relieve pain when you just think that you have something that's going to really help you. Is the placebo effect universal? I mean, can all of us be tricked into feeling better by placebos? Or is it more like hypnosis, say, where some people are more susceptible than others? There's a tremendous amount of variability in placebo effects, including what are the factors that give rise to it and who is susceptible? And so at this point, you know, with these decades of wonderful studies, we know that it depends on a lot of things. There's not one placebo effect, but many placebo effects.
所以有时这些效应是由人们的期望产生的。因此，如果你对治疗有积极的期望，这可能会导致你对刺激的重要性进行不同的评估，无论是疼痛、瘙痒、咳嗽还是你正在经历的任何其他体验。当你对重要性的评估不同时，情况就会改变。所以这算是它的一支。另一个分支是情绪状态。你知道，假设你进来时对因疼痛而残疾感到非常焦虑，而你意识到其实有帮助。这改变了你的情绪状态。第三个分支是前概念联想。我之前提到过你的脊髓可以自己学会走路。好吧，单单脑干，如果与大脑其余部分分离，就能学会将身体中的威胁性刺激接触与痛苦的电击联系起来。所以它在预测接下来会发生什么，并且可以被条件反射来作出反应。因此，这些类型的联想是由整个大脑、脊髓、脑干中连接在一起的神经回路形成的，并且在整个大脑其余部分的各种方式中确实形成了。因此，这些前概念联想，我的意思是情境，就像你在特定的地点、环境、医院、以前的接触中接受了治疗，当你再次进入相同的环境时，这些线索就会触发反应。或者，如果我连续几天给你注射像吗啡这样的药物，注射本身、它的感觉、它的外表就是一个情境，在那个条件反射过程之后，它本身就会触发类似吗啡的反应。
So sometimes these effects are created by people's expectations. So if you have positive expectations about treatment, that might cause you to evaluate the significance of a stimulus differently, whether it's pain or itch or cough or any other experience that you. you're having. And when you evaluate the significance differently, then that changes. So that's sort of one branch of it. Another branch is emotional states. You know, let's say you come in really anxious about being disabled by pain and you realize that there's actually help. That changes your emotional state. And a third branch, pre-conceptual associations. I mentioned before that your spinal cord can learn to walk on its own. Well, your brain stem alone, separated from the rest of the brain, can learn to connect threatening stimuli in the body touch with painful shocks. So it's predicting what's coming
因此，无论注射中是否涉及吗啡，你都会对它产生反应。没错。甚至没有吗啡也可以。所以你在第一天、第二天、第三天用吗啡注射，然后单独注射没有吗啡的成分。法比西奥·贝内德蒂（Fabrizio Benedetti）和阿曼齐奥（Amanzio）在9年代末的一些非常出色的研究中证明了这一点。然后你会得到内源性阿片样物质反应。如果你给予阿片受体阻滞剂纳洛酮（naloxone），你可以阻断这种反应。所以这是一个条件反射。所以我可以继续说下去。我的意思是，我不会说太久。但条件性免疫抑制是另一个非常令人惊讶的现象，因为它确实是一种生理反应。所以你将一些线索，比如草莓味的饮料（例如，新颖的风味），
next and it can be conditioned to respond. So those kinds of associations are formed by neural circuits wiring together throughout your brain, in your spinal cord, in your brain stem, and really in various ways throughout the rest of your brain. And so these pre-conceptual associations, I mean that the context, like you took a, you got a treatment in a particular place, setting, hospital, contacts before, and when you enter that same context again, those cues trigger a response. Or if I give you an injection of a drug like morphine on several days in a row, that injection itself, the feeling of it, the look of it, is a context that will then trigger a morphine-like response by itself after that conditioning process.
与免疫抑制药物配对。然后，曼弗雷德·沙洛夫斯基（Manfred Schedlowski）在过去十年左右的时间里做了大量这方面的工作，你知道的，然后你将这种味道和药物配对好几天，然后单独给出这种饮料，你就可以测量到免疫抑制反应。我们正在了解是什么创造了这一点。好吧，是什么创造了这一点呢？是大脑下行的通路，特别是岛叶（insula）通过内脏神经向下延伸到体内，从而触发免疫行为（免疫细胞）的变化。所以这真的很惊人，对吧？因为岛叶是大脑中对安慰剂效应非常重要的一个中心。当你得到一种假药时，你在想，你认为疼痛会变好还是变坏，你会以不同的方式激活岛叶。这随后可以触发发生的许多过程，甚至是体内的真实生理过程。好了，为了总结这一点。
So whether or not there's morphine involved in the injection, you'll have a reaction to it. That's right. Even without. So you do, you do, you know, injection with morphine on day one, day two, day three, and then injection alone with no morphine. And Fabicio Benedetti and Amanzio demonstrated this in some really wonderful studies in the late 90s. Then you get a endogenous opioid response. And if you give the opioid blocker, naloxone, you can block that response. So it's a condition. So I can go on. I mean, I won't go on too long. But conditioned immunosuppression is another one that's really surprising because it's really a physiological response. So you pair cues like a strawberry-flavored drink, for example, novel flavor,
你之前问过谁容易受到安慰剂效应的影响，谁不受影响。我给了你这个冗长的答案，有很多因素。这很复杂，对吧？确实如此。关键是，谁会对安慰剂效应产生反应？预测这一点一直是百万美元的问题。这将取决于许多因素。这将取决于你先前的经历。这将取决于你的心态以及你对某些类型信息的接受程度。但归根结底，我们认为这很大程度上归结为你的大脑认为正在发生什么事情
with an immunosuppressive drug. And then, in manfred, Shalowski has done a lot of this work recently over the past decade or so, you know, then you pair the taste and the drug for over several days and you give the drink alone and you can measure an immunosuppressive response. And we're learning about what creates that. Well, what creates that are descending pathways from the brain, in particular the insula down through the splenic nerve and down into the body that trigger changes in immune behavior, the immune cells. So that's really stunning, right? Because the insula is a center in the brain that's really important for placebo effects. When you get a fake drug, you're thinking, you think that pain's
发生在你身上。这具有威胁性还是安全的？这个决定在某种程度上是无意识的，但它将塑造你的大脑和身体如何做出反应。有各种各样的方法可以触及大脑的那个核心决定。例如，如果你买的是昂贵的止痛药而不是便宜的止痛药，而且你知道它很贵。这似乎会引发更强的镇痛反应。这有点像红酒。没错。事实上，其中一些相同的大脑回路似乎也参与其中，对吧？有一个，克里斯蒂安·巴克尔（Christian Büchel）和他的实验室人员通过一系列非常漂亮的整个研究证明了这一点。大脑中有一个区域，即腹内侧前额叶皮层（VMPFC），当你喝着你认为昂贵且极好的红酒时，这个区域就会被激活。并且你更喜欢这种红酒，你的VMPFC就被激活了。好吧，同样的道理。如果你得到的安慰剂，你认为它是一种昂贵的、很好的疼痛安慰剂，一种很好的止痛药，你就会激活你的腹内侧前额叶皮层，这就触发了一条从你的前额叶皮层到脑干再到脊髓的通路，可以调节那些早期的感觉。鉴于大约20%的美国人经历过慢性疼痛，我们的听众中可能有一些人属于这个数字。你对他们有什么建议吗？如果他们
going to be better versus worse, you activate the insula differently. That then can trigger many processes that happen and even real physiological processes in the body. Okay, so just to wrap this up. You asked before about who's susceptible to placebo effects and who's not. And I gave you this long-winded answer, lots of factors. It's complex, right? And that's right. And the thing is, who's going to respond to a placebo effect? Predicting that has been a million dollar question. And it's going to depend on lots of factors. It's going to depend on your prior experiences. It's going to depend on your mindset and how receptive you are to certain kinds of information. But at the end of the day, we think a lot of it boils down to what your brain thinks is happening
正在寻找探索基于心理学的治疗是否能帮助他们的方法，他们应该从哪里开始？有很多地方可以开始。我认为其中一个地方是一系列书籍。有许多作者写过关于慢性疼痛体验的书籍。就在我脑海中浮现的，霍华德·舒比纳（Howard Schubiner）有一本书叫《戒掉你的疼痛》（Unlearn Your Pain），其中概括了我们一直在讨论的许多原则。艾伦·戈登（Alan Gordon）刚刚写了一本名为《出路》（The Way Out）的书，专门讲述PRT。大卫·汉斯科姆（David Hanscom）写了很多书。他曾是一名外科医生，他某种程度上意识到许多手术实际上是有害的，从那以后他一直在探索背痛和其他类型疼痛的心理学。我想他的书叫
to you. And is this threatening or safe? And that decision is partly unconscious, but that's going to shape how your brain and how your body respond. There's various ways of getting at that, that core sort of decision by the brain. So, for example, if you are buying an expensive painkiller versus a cheap one, and you know it's expensive. That seems to trigger a stronger analgesic response. It's kind of like wine. That's right. In fact, some of the same brain circuitry seems to be involved, right? There's a, and Christian Buckel and people in his lab have showed this over a whole series of studies
对你来说。这到底是具有威胁性还是安全的？这个决定部分是无意识的，但这将塑造你的大脑和身体的反应方式。有多种方法可以触及大脑核心的这种决策。所以，举个例子，如果你买了一款昂贵的止痛药与便宜的相比，而且你知道它是贵的那种。这似乎会触发更强的止痛反应。这有点像酒。没错。事实上，其中一些相同的大脑神经回路似乎也参与其中，对吧？有一个，克里斯蒂安·巴克尔（Christian Buckel）和他的实验室成员通过一系列的研究展示了这一点
that are really beautiful. There's an area of the brain, the ventrometrial prefrontal cortex, that is the area that is activated when you're drinking wine that you think is expensive and great wine. And you like the wine more, and your VMPFC is activated. Well, the same thing. If you get a placebo that you think is an expensive, great placebo for pain, a great drug for pain, you activate your ventured media prefrontal cortex, and that triggers a pathway from your prefrontal cortex to your brainstem to your spinal cord that can modulate those early sensations. Given that some 20% of Americans experience chronic pain, we probably have some, listeners among that number. Do you have any advice for them? Where should they start if they're
这些研究非常精妙。大脑中有一个区域，即腹内侧前额叶皮层，这是当你喝你认为昂贵且极好的酒时会被激活的区域。你会更喜欢这种酒，你的腹内侧前额叶皮层（VMPFC）就会被激活。好吧，同样的事情。如果你得到了一个安慰剂，你认为它是一种昂贵、极好的止痛安慰剂，是一种极好的止痛药，你就会激活你的腹内侧前额叶皮层，这会触发一条从你的前额叶皮层到脑干再到脊髓的通路，从而调节那些早期的感觉。鉴于大约有20%的美国人经历慢性 pain（慢性疼痛），我们听众中可能也有这样的人。你对他们有什么建议吗？如果他们想开始
looking to explore whether psychological-based treatments could help them? There are many places to start. I think one of those places is a series of books. And there's a number of authors who have written books about the chronic pain experience. Just off the top of my head right now, Howard Schubiner has a book called Unlearn Your Pain, which encapsulates a lot of the principles that we've been discussing. Alan Gordon just wrote a book called The Way Out, which is about PRT specifically. David Hanscom has written a lot. He was a former surgeon who sort of realized that a lot of surgeries were actually harmful, and he's been exploring the psychology of back pain and other kinds of pain ever since. I think his book's called
寻找并探索基于心理学的治疗方法是否能帮助他们？有很多可以开始的地方。我认为其中一个地方是一系列的书籍。有很多作者都写过关于慢性疼痛体验的书。我目前能想到的，霍华德·舒比纳（Howard Schubiner）写过一本名为《摆脱你的疼痛》（Unlearn Your Pain）的书，其中总结了我们一直在讨论的许多原则。阿兰·戈登（Alan Gordon）刚刚写了一本名为《出路》（The Way Out）的书，专门讲述PRT。大卫·汉斯科姆（David Hanscom）写了很多书。他曾是一名外科医生，后来意识到许多手术其实是有害的，从那以后他一直在探索背痛和其他类型疼痛的心理学。我想他的书名叫
Back in Control. And so there's these ideas from books. pain psychology is real. It is possibly the best and most effective way to adjust how the brain's responding to pain in a fine-tuned kind of way. You know, to think about taking a drug for pain, you know, gabapentin or SSRI. This is a blunt instrument that, frankly, as, you know, it may work for some people, and that's wonderful. But it's just having lots of effects on all kinds of systems in your brain.
重新掌控。因此，这些书里有一些观点：疼痛心理学是真实的。这可能是以一种精细的方式调整大脑对疼痛反应的最有效方法。你知道的，考虑吃止痛药，比如加巴喷丁或选择性5-羟色胺再摄取抑制剂（SSRI）。这是一种生硬的手段，坦白讲，虽然它可能对某些人有效，这很好，但它会对你大脑中的各种系统产生大量影响。
brain and body and lots of side effects. So it's not targeted, whereas psychological therapies can really target the core beliefs that give rise to this cycle of perpetuating pain and try to work with those beliefs. So even if there's real pain from a real injury and real physical process is happening, psychology can be helpful. And so I think a lot of major medical centers have pain psychologists. So getting to see a pain specialist. you know, can be really helpful, especially one who's been trained in pain psychology as well. And I think there's some of those in, you know, academic medical centers all over the country. Alan Gordon runs a pain psychology center in L.A.
包括大脑和身体，并带来许多副作用。因此它不具备针对性，而心理疗法则能真正针对引发这种持续疼痛循环的核心信念，并试着去处理这些信念。因此，即使是由真正伤情和真实生理过程引起的真实疼痛，心理学也能提供帮助。所以我想很多大型医疗中心都配有疼痛心理学家。因此，去看一位疼痛专家，你知道的，会非常有帮助，尤其是那些也接受过疼痛心理学培训的专家。我认为全国各地的学术医疗中心里都有这样的人。阿伦·戈登在洛杉矶运营着一个疼痛心理学中心。
And so they all do telehealth consultations as well. But you can kind of start on your own by reading a couple of these books and then see if you need more help. That's basically what you're saying. That's right. It won't hurt you to read the book. think. And you know, I have to say, too, that I know people now and people in my family and my friends who have been exposed to these ideas. And what happens is, and it's not for everybody, some people say, nope, that's not me. But some people, I've seen this happen with people where
而且他们也进行远程医疗咨询。但你基本上可以通过自己阅读几本书来开始，然后看看是否需要更多的帮助。这基本上就是你想表达的意思。没错。读这本书不会对你有什么坏处，我是这么想的。你知道的，我也必须说，我现在认识一些人，包括我家族里的人和我的朋友，他们都接触过这些理念。所发生的情况是——虽然这并不适合所有人，有些人会说，不，那不是我——但有些人，我确实见过这种情况，那就是
they say, wow, that's me. You know, this process is me. And they read a book or they go to a course and they get better. So my student, the student who did this was the first author of this JMA psychiatry paper that we just published, and he led the study and organized it and did, he was really wonderful. I mean, he really took this on as his own. And he started this as his PhD dissertation project. And the reason he took this on, and we decided on this together, was that he, you know, was looking for a project. And he came to me one day and said, you know, I've had chronic back pain for several years. I didn't tell you this, but I went to this training program with Howard Schubiner and
他们会说，哇，那就是我。你知道的，这个过程就是我。他们读了一本书或者参加了一个课程，然后病就好了。所以我的学生，做这件事的学生是我们刚刚发表的这篇《美国医学会杂志·精神病学》论文的第一作者，他领导并组织了这项研究，表现得非常出色。我的意思是，他真的把这当成了自己的事。他将此作为他的博士学位论文项目开始推进。他之所以接手这个项目，也是我们共同决定的，是因为他当时正在寻找一个项目。有一天他来找我说，你知道的，我有多年的慢性背痛。我之前没告诉你，但我参加了霍华德·舒比纳和
Alan Gordon and it worked for me. My back pain is gone. I want to study this. I had somebody in my lab tell me they've had shoulder pain for several years and they, they went to a lab meeting and were exposed to these ideas and they thought that's me and their shoulder pain resolved. It can work. Yeah, that's amazing. And I think that's very helpful. I really appreciate that advice. And I want to thank you for joining me today to talk about your research. I think this is really fascinating. I'm going to go take a placebo right now. And I'm sure I'll feel much better at the end of the day. So thank you for joining us, Dr. Weager.
阿伦·戈登的培训项目，它对我管用了。我的背痛消失了。我想研究这个。我实验室里曾有人告诉我，他们有多年的肩痛，他们在参加实验室会议时接触到了这些理念，然后他们觉得“这就是我”，接着他们的肩痛就消失了。这真的管用。是的，太神奇了。我认为这非常有帮助。我非常感谢你的建议，并感谢你今天能来和我谈谈你的研究。我认为这真的非常吸引人。我打算现在就去吃一颗安慰剂，而且我确信到了一天结束时我会感觉好很多。所以谢谢你加入我们，韦格尔博士。
Thank you, Kim. It's been a pleasure. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www.combeingof Psychology.org or on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. That's Speaking of Psychology, all one word, at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condyenne.
谢谢你，金。非常荣幸。您可以在我们的网站 www.combeingof Psychology.org 上，或者在 Apple、Stitcher 以及您获取播客的任何平台上找到《心理学对话》（Speaking of Psychology）之前的单集。如果您对未来的播客有什么评论或想法，可以给我们发邮件：speaking of psychology at APA.org。也就是 speaking of psychology（全部连在一起）@APA.org。《心理学对话》由李·韦纳曼（Lee Weinerman）制作。我们的音响剪辑师是克里斯·孔迪扬（Chris Condyenne）。
Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
谢谢收听。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills），代表美国心理学会。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。